so we know who the new Stargate
showrunner is apparently and it's Thor's
brother
not sure about this one but welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
[Music]
so as you know on Sidetrack I will share
rumors with you and I will tell you
whether it's a rumor that I believe or
whether I don't and I as much as
possible will tell you where I've got
the rumor from in this case this is
actually something that was put around
by giant freaking robot a couple of
months ago so obviously I completely
ignored it because they're full of [ __ ]
but
I've now heard the rumor three separate
occasions from three different sources
of people I speak to two of which
actually don't really believe this has
gone any further than a very brief
conversation if at all but one seems to
actually think there is some weight
behind this and this could actually be
announced again around Christmas so Liam
Hemsworth he's Chris Hemsworth's brother
that's how you know him gin does a
perfect imitation of Liam go for it all
right
he has actually in the past done a
couple of movies one was actually quite
good he was being hunted by like this uh
um rich people who like pay him a
million pounds if he survives 24 hours
sort of thing
um it was actually quite good they
tricked me to believe him he's dying so
that's the only reason he agrees to it
he actually executive produced that
movie though is my point and he has been
known to produce an executive produce a
couple of other movies
don't forget that if you enjoy the
content you can hit the join button and
become a fully fledged side tracker that
really helps out the channel you can go
to cygashtrack.com there's loads of like
merchandise things on there and a load
of new designs coming very soon also if
you are new to the channel don't forget
to like subscribe and hit the Bell
notifications so you miss none of our
new videos as well as the Sidetrack
sides channel so what I've been told is
that he's been approached that Amazon
would actually like a well-known quite a
big name to be attached to the new
Stargate franchise they seem to think
that Liam Hemsworth is that name even if
it is mainly through association with
his brother he is a reasonably young
actor he would bring an element of
Gravitas to whatever role he then did
and he has actually got experience
behind the camera doing the Dirty Work
that a showrunner would have to do as
well
according to my source again another
reason why there is such a big delay is
that negotiating with Liam Hemsworth has
been quite difficult he is quite
demanding he's got very set ideas about
what he wants to do with Stargate if he
were to sign on the dotted line one of
the main things he wants to do
apparently is to do a movie first now I
can kind of understand that and this is
something that Amazon have actually
talked a great deal about about doing a
movie first and then a series I told you
guys got eight or nine months ago that
their ideal scenario with star game was
that they would get the purchase of MGM
done reasonably quickly which to be fair
they did but they would start off with a
movie that would appear on our screens
some point next year 2023 and then have
a series behind it the idea being that a
big movie for MGM or epics or MGM Plus
um or even on Amazon Prime would really
get the ball rolling would get some
attention and then follow it up
immediately after with a series so okay
let's assume for a second that this is
true
probably isn't but let's assume it is
just for a second what do we think about
this news
so I quite likely in hence with he's
quite a likeable actor he's not the you
know the big movie star that Chris is
um but he's got similar attributes he's
a good looking fella and he does bring
um like I said earlier a little bit of
Gravitas too this people will know the
actor
um I quite like um if Amazon are serious
about this that they are really serious
about investing in the Stargate
franchise investing in a movie and then
a series something I assume would
actually be in Liam Hemsworth's contract
before he signed on that we would have
an element of security that we're at
least going to get a movie and so many
episodes of a series to follow up with
it's not necessarily certain that he
would then appear in the series maybe
this is something he's going to appear
in the movie and but then won't appear
in the series but then then maybe
there'd be a couple of movies down the
road who knows
I could actually see this is something
sort of gleam pens with would be into if
he is a Stargate fan I don't know but if
he is then maybe again this is something
that he'd be up to before because it's a
big project he seems to like these sort
of projects he's not happy just acting
he's obviously wants to get behind the
camera he wants to be involved in the
management side of things as well so
again this would allow him to do that
does it make sense with some of the
other rumors we've heard
I don't know what Liam Hemsworth is up
to at the moment from what I've heard if
this is again true that there is
something he's signed on to at least
till Christmas that's prevented him from
agreeing now
but
mainly that issue is not actually that
he signed on to something it's just it's
quite a long negotiation so they're
expecting him to sign by Christmas
because I was not actually specifically
told they were contracted to something I
was specifically told they couldn't sign
on or they weren't expecting this person
to sign on until Christmas
so maybe that's been a bit of a
miscommunication maybe there's a little
bit more to that but I am wildly
speculating another rumor though that
Mark Fergus and Hawk ostby have been
setting up sort of like a Bible for the
franchise moving forward developing the
story creating as I say this Canon Bible
um basically doing all the groundwork
for a new show it kind of makes sense in
that it makes sense for somebody to go
in and do all the homework and actually
get prepared for a show maybe and then
to also support Liam Hemsworth because
if this is a project he's never done
before
so again maybe that makes sense but
again we are speculating
so what do I actually think about this
rumor
well it started on giant freaking robot
so my instinct is that I don't believe
it but sometimes giant freaking robot do
get things right as I said over a year
ago I started Sidetrack by reporting a
story from giant freaking robot before I
learned how much of a click betting site
they are
that
the Stargate franchise was hoping to
start off with a TV series and an
animated series now that then got
scrapped
but it actually did turn out that it was
kind of true the executive producer in
charge of things before Michael Wright
did want to use the MGM Animation Studio
that wasn't particularly being utilized
well at the time to create a Stargate
series they were looking at basically
Star Trek and lower decks at the time
and they thought yeah let's do that
Michael Wright thankfully came in and
put a Kai Bosh on that and said no don't
be stupid our Animation Studio is crap
and actually scrapped it now is no MGM
Animation Studio currently which if you
think about mgm's animation history Tom
and Jerry Accenture is kind of
disgusting so let's hope that gets a
comeback under Amazon at some point hand
on heart I completely dismissed this
rumor until I began hearing it from
other sources as well so I'm going to
say on this one I'm going to give you a
percentage
I would say maybe 20 this is true I I'm
gonna say that it's possible it's true
but if it is I would be very very
surprised but hey guys get in the
comments and tell me what you think do
you think there is any chance that this
room is true or because it starred on
giant freaking robot are you throwing it
in the trash like I did initially
get in the comments and tell me exactly
what you think and if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification really helps us out
and if you enjoy the content and you
want to support the channel consider
hitting the join button as always guys
please stay safe and I'll see you next
time
[Music]